I read polls about religious belief with
great interest and in many of these
polls the following question is asked do
you believe in God most of the time the
responses are broken down into yes/no or
don't know naathan seems to me that the
first thing one should do when asked by
a pollster if he or she believes in God
is to ask the questioner what do you
mean by God if you tell me what you mean
I'll tell you whether I believe the
reason for this is that there are so
many conceptions of God that grouping
all of the yes answers into one category
doesn't tell us much about what those
people actually believe or what the
people who answer know are actually
denying there's a wide range of
conceptions of God and we need to
explore some of the most commonly held
beliefs in almost every tradition we're
going to study we're going to encounter
various supernatural beings God God's
spirits so on the category of divinity
is one of the five key themes that will
encounter in almost every religious
tradition and the purpose of this
lecture is to examine each of these
categories in addition to divinity the
other four categories are scripture
ritual good and evil and soteriology or
the doctrine of salvation or liberation
will gain some general knowledge about
these important aspects of religion
which will help prepare us for our study
the world's religions
why not begin our study of religious
themes thinking about the biggest topic
of all God but before we even begin we
have a problem with language perhaps
it's not even a good idea to just use
the word God to describe all the views
we'll discuss is that word tends to
invoke the God of the Bible or Quran
which might be misleading when talking
about the gods of non monotheistic
religions some scholars use more general
terms such as divinity or ultimate
reality to refer to the realm of being
that is beyond the human and of supreme
importance people who believe in some
kind of God or gods are called theists
after the word fails from the Greek for
God that's where we get the term
theology a discourse or understanding
about God that words related to the
Latin deus from which we get words like
deity and divine those who believe that
there's no God are atheists and
agnostics are those who do not know
whether there's a God or not Gnostics
believe that if we do not or cannot have
knowledge about God's existence the only
responsible position is I don't know
some scholars have argued that simply
asking people whether or not they
believe in God isn't sufficient to
really capture the attitude people have
towards the existence of a deity for one
thing it does not tell us how they
conceive of God and second it doesn't
tell us how confidently they hold the
belief Richard Dawkins came up with a
seven-point scale to determine people's
believes with more precision try to
locate where you are on this scale
category 1 absolute certainty in the
existence of God to high degree of
confidence in the existence of God but
with some doubt 3 leaning toward belief
in existence but with less confidence 4
completely neutral there's an equal
degree of probability that there is or
is not a God 5 leaning toward rejection
of the belief in God 6 high degree of
confidence that God does not exist but
with some doubt seven absolute certainty
in the non-existence of God now simply
asking people the yes/no question do you
believe in God it makes it seem like
there's only ones and sevens out there
however in the many years that I've been
asking students to locate themselves on
this scale I find that the majority fall
in categories two through six
many people have at least some doubts
and after that it's a matter of degree
so rather than ask yourself whether or
not you believe in God ask yourself
where on the scale you would be when we
turn to conceptions of God we find a
number of categories that determine the
nature of people's beliefs so first the
number of God's how many are there
according to the latest statistics over
half of the world's population believes
in one God it's proximately 55% it's a
very rough estimate in other words they
are mono theists monotheists believe in
one Supreme Being and emphasize the
unity of that being although there are
doctrines like the Trinity that believe
in different persons or aspects within
the one God the reason for the high
percentage of monotheists is the large
number of Christians and Muslims who
together make up about half the world's
population along with smaller numbers of
Jews Sikhs the highs and other
monotheists but at the same time there
are more religious traditions that are
polytheistic meaning a belief in many
gods from Chinese folk religions and
Shinto in East Asia to numerous
indigenous traditions in Africa
Australia and Central and South America
many religions of antiquity including
the classical Greek and Roman religions
as well as the Celtic were polytheistic
there are many varieties of polytheism
normally the gods are organized into
Pantheon's although this may be done in
different ways in some cases each God
occupies a different plane of existence
or has a different function and these
deities do not interact with each other
much but in most cases the gods do
interact with each other often making
alliances or fighting marrying or
engaging in other
activities that parallel those of the
human realm in some way in some cases
the gods arranged in a hierarchy in
Chinese folk religion as we'll see the
gods staff a cosmic bureaucracy in some
cultures individuals or communities
worship multiple gods but in other cases
people worship one God but recognize the
existence of other gods another belief
system is pantheism which is derived
from the root pan or all and that's the
belief that God is identical with the
universe or at least the natural
universe the natural world is itself
divine some forms of Taoism can be seen
this way for example monotheism's
emphasis on oneness normally takes the
form of a single being who creates a
world like a craftsman creates an object
so the creators related to the world but
it's not identical with it but
pantheists see all of reality is one
there's no duality between the divine
and the natural world in some of his
writings Albert Einstein who described
himself as an agnostic leans in this
direction while he rejected a belief in
a personal God he wrote quote if
something is in me which can be called
religious then it is the unbounded
admiration for the structure of the
world so far as our science can reveal
it finally there are traditions such as
n Buddhism that do not feature God gods
or supernatural beings rather than
focusing on external beings with whom we
can relate such traditions emphasize
uncovering the spiritual possibilities
within ourselves the next question that
can be asked is what form if any does
God or the gods take in some traditions
there is the emphasis on a formless God
is there's a concern that any attempt to
picture or represent God limits an
infinite being and leads to idolatry the
worship of the image instead of God
however some believe that it's difficult
to have a personal relationship with an
abstract formless impersonal deity for
them a God with form is easier to relate
to
some traditions also teach that
directing one's worship toward a
representation can help to focus one on
the divine when deities are understood
to possess form they're quite often seen
as being similar to human beings and
this is known as anthropomorphism which
means attributing human form and
characteristics to the deities gods are
portrayed as having basically human-like
bodies but often with variations like
more arms and legs greater stature and
power abilities humans don't have
immortality so on
the gods are also seen as possessing
human emotions such as anger compassion
love and jealousy what particular kinds
of images do people have of God when
people talk about God and are searching
for ways to describe a being that's
often understood is infinite
transcendent and ineffable they have no
choice but to look for metaphors I mean
all we know is our human world
so believers need to think of God and
their relationship with God in terms
they can understand so think about the
various images of God that people have
beginning with God as a parent if God
has created us loves us guides us and
watches over us what better metaphor is
there than a parental one one issue that
arises with the parental metaphor
involves gender in traditional
monotheism God is frequently described
as Father but if this language is just
metaphorical and God doesn't really have
a gender then why not also refer to God
as mother aren't many of God's
characteristics reflective of a mother's
care as much as a father's if when we
picture God we picture a man what does
that mean for how we'll view men and
women within religious traditions
another common image is God as ruler
Lord or judge these images emphasize
God's authority in God's activity of
dispensing justice but in many
traditions people have metaphors that
move away from focusing on God's power
and authority and instead focuses on
God's love and compassion
here we see conceptions of God as friend
or in some cases as our beloved we'll
see religious poetry that uses romantic
passionate imagery to talk about the
longing of the soul for union with God
and in some traditions God can be
portrayed as a child or even a baby
images of innocence purity and even
playfulness can be seen in some
traditions on the other side of the
spectrum God can sometimes be seen as a
destroyer a being whose wrathful and
bloodthirsty in some traditions gods are
seen as having the forms of animals or
human animal hybrids in other cases the
natural elements themselves the Sun
stars or fire can themselves be seen as
deities rather than think of a
human-like deity associated with the
element who controls the element the
natural element or object itself is
worshipped we'll see examples of all of
these in the coming lectures
we now move to our second category
scripture I'd like you to think of the
following situation you arrive in a
place you've never been experiencing a
culture you know absolutely nothing
about the language they speak has no
general word for scripture how would you
find out what their scriptures are if
they have any if you knew the language
could you find the texts or texts that
could be considered scripture too many
or all people within that culture I mean
what features would it have to have
would it consists of stories laws and
rules poetry philosophy history in the
religions we're going to study we'll see
examples of all of these genres and many
more and of course there are plenty of
non scriptural books that contain these
genres so if there's nothing
specifically about the content of a book
that can tell us if it's a scripture
what can i would argue that to determine
which book the culture considers
scripture you have to watch the way that
practitioners of that religion relate to
certain books what will people do in
relationship to a scripture well as
we'll see they often chanted recited in
community rituals cover it with
decorative adornment memorize it compose
commentaries about it write it in
beautiful calligraphy give lectures and
sermons about it
put it in a special location but most
importantly it will be used as an
authority and people in the culture will
understand its words to contain
important truths and will attempt to
guide their lives by it recognized
authority figures like priests scholars
theologians and jurists will attempt to
settle disputes set up legal codes
organize institutions and communities
and provide guidance and wisdom by
consulting the text in other words the
status of Scripture comes to a text not
simply through its own features but
through a relationship between the text
and a community and we must ask another
question about these sacred words how
are they to be understood what do they
mean how do we interpret
texts and who has the authority to judge
the truth and validity of
interpretations this will be a central
question that arises in every tradition
very few people treat every passage of a
scripture is equally important with
other passages which passages are
emphasized by particular communities or
individuals should passages be
interpreted literally metaphorically
with the help of other texts what
scholarly method should be applied to
scriptures so these are questions that
religious people of all traditions
struggle with
we now move to our third category ritual
while some traditions might lack a
conception of God or a written scripture
all of them feature rituals when we
think about our lives we can see that
they're structured in numerous ways by
ritual activity from our daily rituals
to important rituals at certain moments
in our lives to large-scale rituals
carried out by a religious institution
or the state but what exactly is a
ritual and how does it differ from a
habit or a routine here's one way to
think about it as opposed to a habit or
routine ritual is characterized by
symbolic action certain body movements
and verbal expressions often accompanied
by the use of certain objects but are
not just practical ways to get something
done so on this understanding we would
not say that brushing our teeth is a
ritual just because we do it every day
but ritual can encompass those small
gestures and words that characterize our
day-to-day interactions insofar as they
constitute agreed on patterns and forms
that we carry out in our communities so
these would include shaking hands or
bowing or giving a toast at dinner in a
religious context rituals can be
understood as the formalized movements
and language that are given to us by our
traditions
and are carried out in contexts that are
understood as sacred rituals can be
divided into a number of categories one
type of ritual is the life cycle ritual
these are often called rites of passage
as they mark a transition from one state
to the next
the major passages that are covered in
almost all traditions are birth
coming-of-age marriage and death events
like birth and death are biological
events of course but there's also a
profoundly important cultural dimension
a new baby becomes a member of a
particular religious community for
example through a ritual such as baptism
or circumcision or a naming ceremony
a death is marked by a ritual that
enables a transition both for the
deceased and for the survivors in the
cases of coming-of-age and wedding there
is not a single biological event that's
given cultural meaning by the ritual
rather the ritual itself is what brings
about the change in status in the eyes
of a religious community a couple is
married only when the proper ritual is
completed so the proper series of
gestures and words can in fact bring
about a new reality this is the power of
ritual another category is nature based
rituals and these are cyclic seasonal
celebrations such rituals connect human
beings up with the movements of the
larger natural world cultivating a sense
of gratitude and reverence for nature
and in some cases the god or gods who
create and sustain the natural world the
most common of these are the rituals
that occur during solstices and
equinoxes these are important rituals in
nature based traditions from the pagan
traditions that predate Christianity to
later traditions that drawn them such as
Wicca but they can also be seen in
monotheistic traditions that often
incorporate these seasonal rituals into
their own historically based rituals
that's why Passover an Easter shares so
many elements with spring rituals and
Christmas with the winter solstice this
brings us to historically based rituals
these are rituals that commemorate
important events in the history of a
tradition in many cases this might be an
event related to the founder of the
tradition such as the birth or death
these kinds of rituals are important in
Christianity and Buddhism for instance
historically based rituals can also
involve pivotal events in the formation
of the community or tradition such as
the Jewish Exodus commemorated and
Passover the revelation of the Quran to
Muhammad commemorated during Ramadan or
the enlightenment of the Buddha marked
during Bodhi Day rituals can infuse our
ordinary lives with a sense of the
sacred reflect on the ways that our
shared meals are transformed through
ritual from the bile
logical act of eating to a cultural
expression of togetherness
think of how ritual guides the ways we
express respect gratitude or remorse to
each other or help us navigate the act
of meeting a stranger as we look at
rituals in the world's religious
traditions and the lectures ahead we'll
see that they serve many functions and
accomplish many ends they connect human
beings with ultimate reality as they
conceive it that's what we might call a
vertical connection and they connect
people with each other in communities
it's a horizontal connection they also
connect people with their tradition and
its history educating them about the
beliefs and values of the tradition and
commemorating historical events rituals
enable human beings to navigate
difficult transitions such as the death
of a loved one and bring about new
realities such as the change in status
of a child to adult single to married
layperson to priests ritual cultivates
and expresses feelings attitudes and
worldviews
I mean think of the way that music art
and architecture the stylized movement
of bodies and special clothing the
reciting of prayers and sacred texts can
put you in a certain mood and frame of
mind can awaken powerful feelings in you
or make you see the world in a different
way
we now enter the realm of good and evil
religious traditions have to account for
why their suffering and evil in the
world and offer a way to understand and
cope with it it's during difficult times
that many people are likely to turn
toward religion as they seek comfort and
meaning with all of the profound
differences that exist among religious
traditions they all seem to share at
least one thing a belief that there's
some basic order in the cosmos it's hard
to imagine a religious tradition that
would state that everything simply
random that there's no justice no larger
pattern no meaning and yet when we look
at the world it certainly seems that
there's some truth in the following news
story from the satirical newspaper the
onion with its headline life unfair for
the 50 billions consecutive weeks since
its inception life was revealed to be
unfair Monday death and suffering
continue to be dispersed randomly among
the planets life forms with such
potentially mitigating factors as solid
community standing genetic superiority
and previous good works in no way taken
into account the articles conclusion
life is expected to remain unfair far
into the foreseeable future
well religious traditions have to find a
compelling way to counter this claim
monotheistic traditions have a challenge
in doing so if God is omniscient or
all-knowing omnipotent all-powerful and
omnibot Evelynn all good why is there
evil in the world the attempt to solve
this problem is called theodicy which
comes from the greek meaning the Justice
of God since God is all-powerful God
can't be unable to end evil and
suffering and since God's all good
he shouldn't be unwilling to end it so
what kind of theodicies are possible
well one theodicy is based on freewill
arguing that God created people with the
freedom to choose good or evil which
means that some will choose evil and
harm others the alternative would have
been to create people unable to choose
evil but then we would be puppets or
automatons not free beings
one of the problems with this attempt is
that it only works to explain the evil
human beings do to each other and not
the suffering caused by natural events
like floods hurricanes famines and
disease other theodicies emphasize that
we grow as people and become strong
through suffering that a full meaningful
life requires struggle and we can't know
joy without sorrow some call this the
soul making theodicy this might be
effective in some context but it's hard
to see how it would apply in a situation
where a child dies and this never has a
chance to grow and learn from the
experience some theodicies advised us to
simply accept that it's all a part of
God's plan that everything will be made
alright in the end
this might mean that we receive rewards
and punishments after each of us dies so
that any theming in justice is rectified
it also might be connected with
eschatology theories about the end times
where the balancing out happens in a new
age or Kingdom some theologians have
been unsatisfied with these attempts to
make sense of evil and suffering and so
they've come to understand God
differently perhaps God is not
omnipotent after all perhaps God is not
the kind of being who can directly
intervene in human affairs maybe God
only acts in cooperation with or through
human beings providing a source of power
from whom human beings can derive
strength for some feel Logan's God is
not the one who can prevent suffering
God is the one who suffers with us God
cannot prevent bad things from happening
but can be a source of solace when they
do it's also important to note the
traditions that are not theistic also
have to come up with theodicies and
these also have their weaknesses as
we'll see many Asian traditions feature
a belief in karma and rebirth the law of
cause and effect where our actions good
and bad lead to good and bad results
later in this life or in a future life
these systems can account for seemingly
unjust suffering by seeing it
as a result of past Karma perhaps from a
previous life but some think thinkers
have critiqued this way of thinking by
arguing that it seems to say that
whatever it happens to one is deserved
in some way like a way of blaming the
victim many forms of karma theory avoid
this result but inevitably all Fiat is's
run into difficulties struggle with evil
and suffering it's one of the most
profound challenges that all religious
traditions have to face religious
traditions are not only concerned with
explaining and addressing the problem of
evil but also with the pursuit of the
good ethical questions include how
should I live what is good and bad right
and wrong one version of religious
ethics states simply that we know what's
moral by looking at God's commandments
but this raises many problems such as
how do we interpret and apply these
Commandments and what happens when what
appears to be a command conflicts with
our conscience just imagine being in
abraham's position and being commanded
to kill your child many forms of ethics
focus on the rightness or wrongness of
actions but ethical judgment can also
focus on people such forms of ethics
emphasize character cultivation and the
development of virtues and are therefore
known as character or virtue ethics
classical Greek and Chinese ethics are
of this kind and both center on the most
important virtues and how to cultivate
them in other words instead of focusing
on individual actions you work to become
a good person with guidance from your
tradition and then good actions will
flow from your character so if you're a
compassionate generous fair person then
you will act in these ways without
having to calculate the right thing to
do in each situation virtually every
religious tradition has an element of
virtue ethics and it's instructive to
compare the virtues that are considered
the most important in each tradition
think about the cardinal virtues in the
traditions of classical Greek thought
wisdom justice courage and temperance
Confucianism benevolence propriety
righteousness and wisdom Buddhism
compassion loving kindness sympathetic
joy and equanimity and Christianity
faith hope and charity or unconditional
love we can also compare the various
methods used to cultivate virtuous
characters some traditions advocate
learning some rituals some meditation as
an exercise
think about what set of virtues and try
to limit yourself to four are the most
important for human beings to possess
and what are the most effective methods
for cultivating them as we look at the
various religious traditions
we'll keep thinking about these
questions
we now arrive at our final topic for
this lecture soteriology this word comes
from the Greek word so ter which means
Savior
so soteriology means the doctrine of
salvation or liberation as we've just
discussed religious traditions are guide
to living a good life to understanding
right and wrong virtues and vices but
they're more than that at the highest
level they promise to deliver us from a
profoundly unsatisfactory state to an
infinitely better one which is
understood by terms like salvation
liberation enlightenment for example the
beginning states can be described as sin
a delusion or alienation the final state
as paradise heaven being saved nirvana
and so on but amidst all these
differences we can see a structural
similarity among the traditions
theologian John hick puts it this way
religions all provide a way to move
beyond the initial state which is often
seen as some kind of self-centered state
one of dissatisfaction to the final
state in which one experiences a
profound connection to the ultimate
reality and achieves the highest
spiritual state the path from the
initial to the final state can be
understood as the soteriology the
doctrine of how to be liberated or saved
which includes an understanding of what
that final state is like when we think
about this path and the various
religions we studied we can ask can we
achieve the highest state through our
own efforts or do we need the
intervention of some power beyond us as
we look at the different traditions
we'll examine their diagnosis of what
afflicts us how it can be overcome what
the ultimate goal is and how to achieve
it
and with these questions in mind we now
turn to South Asia and the first
religious tradition we will study
Hinduism